ぐ人は果汁などの液体を吊らチンで固めてできたお菓子の一瞬
今日アール男が具備の歴史を変えようとしていたのだ
それにします眉ですよねはい
[音楽]
大丈夫んん
wh
ちょっと気持ちあるかもですよね慣れないところ
[音楽]
う普通
me
ています
voodoo
んわ
ん
パーティー
ムーラ
[音楽]
んぬー開放感やべぇ
4日
持って
んあぁあれから半同市がたしました
僕の組の方がようやくできまして皆様の僕の方に
組の材料か手入れべってそれが冷えると固まって組になりますこれでは今熱いんですよ
ね
これが冷えると固まって組になります
続きますいきますいますいますいきます
今じゃ防ぎます
一番じゃん
[音楽]
ん
おおーせ
[音楽]
me ん
持った
wash
軍の側市で終わりましたーーー
持って
はいえーと真ん中の十分に固まってないねえっこの後時間を置いて冷やしながら完璧に
固まるのを待ちます
[音楽]
はいそういうわけで固まりました多分めっちゃ重いに強く何キロぐらい
ん
100倍されませんね
近くをちょっと一人だとはを持ち上げられないしひっくり返って方がなくことも
ちょっとキツイんで女の音ランド力を借りてなんとかしてて
組を出せればなと思いますちょっと色々頑張ってみます
飯田市
原田浩逆転するってほどひっくり返った的に
そこがこんな感じ
っていうのはそうだった tc という
のん
[音楽]
こっちの方は上田くん
それを上
[音楽]
うわぁ
でだけ折れてしまいましたこれだけ先にちょっと移動させます
はいはい舐めちゃいまーす
命はでお山になった
やって水の像と言いますか4つない快晴の
そうなんですよこれ
なぁでも&6曲もういいじゃないとこれはいというわけで何度も作っ
サック知事きました
pa
ただ問題こっからですさあ果たして等身大の話社長組はどんな顔しているのでしょうか
肩を落としています
また早稲田明日からでしょう
ほぼ僕をあれ脚がたまらん
まあ
g エディションすごいすごいすごいし方難しい
母
すげー
あーも実はないですねー
[音楽]
はぁっはぁっはぁっ日付で的に行きますか無事いきます指が多分パセティックなって家
を付けする
あやばいまずはた時テレビないですけど
地下部と笑う早いはすげーこっちのでも入っちゃいます
さあ残すな顔と胴体とか阪神のココですねー
開けていきます
[音楽]
同隊は行きましたまた顔へ
良い歯
[音楽]
はっはっは
うっさいくださいはいというわけで宮司いいかを考えるというのはどうしたいんでしょ
特に母全焼した
ありがとうございました
入ったわけで無事弾みシャツを組み完成したんですけども
ちょっと色々細かい点まですごいディティールに凝って作ってあるので見ていき
ましょう
まず脚です小川左足は失敗しましたないです右足はすごいよくできているですねもう何
か僕の足の手話とかまで術とかもですね
すごくきれいに作られておりますはいこれは足の筋肉ですね
すごいですねマジで俺の明日の筋肉と一緒です岐山もうちょっと
バスケやってたじゃんパンツなんでそこも似てますねジャンパー膝の組ですでここが私
は海パン来てたんでなんかこんな感じになってるんですけどもきれいな造りですね
そして腕です何か透け透け感があってきれいだねやばくないですかもう
指の手話まで全部再現されてるんですよこの組やすげー綺麗
ああああああ
綺麗だーなぁなぁとちょっと査定地が寒かったんで見てもらったら分かるけど組が鳥肌
立ってるんですよ方がで撮ってる咲く花ってあの組まで鳥肌が立ってしまいました
鉄骨等御村浦和ですね
はっはっは
草いくらなぁでまつげなく僕の顔ではあるんですよねたぶんストロー加えててこんな口
になってるんですけど
宮良グライガーおっ
あれっ誰ですが立三代女子買ったイカをの揺れはすごいね
完全に僕ですはいそれでさっそく食べてみようと思います
ちょっともったいない気もしますがグリーとは
食べるものなので
ていただいてみようと思いますけどどこから食べようかな
ど所でしょ
視力検査やで俺で遊び放題とか2つ組み右脇腹ざりを食べてみようと思います
右脇腹ですねはい
大丈夫だと思いますいただきます
まず
me
ええええええ